[Musique]
BigFlo, Oli, Squeezie
Freestyle avec les mots Twitter
[Musique]
Jamais deux sans trois
Jamais Alain sans dico
Jamais eux sans moi
Jamais Oli sans Bigflo
Nouvelle mission j'entends sonner mon bipeur
Un freestyle avec squeezie
Des mots choisis sur Twitter
J'suis heureux depuis que je bats des records
Comme un schoïnopentaxophile dans une ville
Où il pleut des cordes
Des heures au conservatoire
J'étais au fond du réfectoire
J'rêvais de gloire
Je regardais le monde dans mon observatoire
Mais dans l'histoire
Trop se sont faits avoir
Moi je fais des super fêtes à trois
Le reste m'est superfératoire
J'suis plein de paradoxes
Mi-sagesse Mi-connerie
J'suis Albert Einstein
Atteint de phénycétonurie
J'freestyle avec amour
Tous vos mots compliqués souvent
Je joue le cabourd
Mais j'suis qu'un foutriquet
Mon son te coupe le souffle
C'est pas de l'asthme
Quand je dis que j'suis mauvais
C'est juste un chleuasme
Quand j'prends le mic' y'a pas photo
Le mauvais rap est aboli
Tu bouges la tête sur tous mes flows
Et quand je gratte ça va trop vite
N'importe quel mot j'en fais un rap c'est de la folie
Genre hexakosioihexekontahexaphobie
Et jamais deux
Sans trois
Si tu l'as su t'es visionnaire
Pardon Alain
Sans toi
On a ouvert le dictionnaire
T'as reconnu
Nos voix
On jongle avec les mots
Tout le monde encore
Une fois
C'est Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo
Pour faire des galipettes sur le canapé
Je cherche une fille callipyge
J'ai percé j'ai beaucoup de succès
J'suis plus le même qu'il y a 10 piges
Méfie toi de l'eau qui dort
A peine
J'ai trop de flow
J'suis le premier rappeut anadyomène
T'es un stéréotype
Un putain d'vieux type
Tellement que tes selfies
C'est des daguerréotypes
Boo
T'as sursauté
Mon rap je te le crie
J'vais pas le chuchoter
Et la nuit dans mon lit
J'me mets à jubjoter
Si j'arrête le rap j'ouvre un bar tabac
J'suis
Le genre de gars qui sait pas s'taper
Bas les masques
Tu peux enlever ton mascara
J'arrive de nulle part
Comme le mascaret
Monte le son mon frérot
Ecoute et profite
Loin des autres morceaux
Aux couplets prolixes
Squeezie Bigflo et Oli
Bientôt tu connais par coeur
Chalunopantaxophile
Donc j'suis toujours à l'heure
Ecoute mes rimes encore c'est de la tentation
J'transforme les mots en or
J'fais de la transsubtantiation
C'est le dernier freestyle
Y'aura pas de nouvel opus
J'te mets une baffe avec la main
D'un therizinosaurus
Et jamais deux
Sans trois
Si tu l'as su t'es visionnaire
Pardon Alain
Sans toi
On a ouvert le dictionnaire
T'as reconnu
Nos voix
On jongle avec les mots
Tout le monde encore
Une fois
C'est Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo
J'suis tout l'inverse d'un mésomorphe
Chétif, fébrile
J'avoue qu'en soirée je suis le mec
Que les filles évitent
Ils prennent leurs fans pour des clients
Ils les fidélisent
Ils veulent des bijoux coruscants
Ils sévissent et se filment
Tôt ou tard le masque tombe
T'es juste antipathique
J'écrirai "FIRST"
Sous tes excuses amphigouriques
Ha ha
Rien n'est inexpugnable
Donc surveille tes arrières
Au fait on a qu'une âme
Fallait pas vendre la tienne
Les temps sont durs les facteurs sont des estafettes
Trois mots de travers dans un tweet
Et c'est ta fête
J'étais fan de Lorie non-stop dans l'euphorie
Aujourd'hui tout m'fait chier
J'embrasse l'adiaphorie
J'crois manier les éléments
J'crois manier le bismuth
Mais j'serai détrôné par ceux qui taffent
Par ceux qui se buttent
Mes draps sentent le pétrichor
J'crois bien qu'elle a aimé
Merci Oli et Bigflo
C'est la fin de l'épopée
Et jamais deux
Sans trois
Si tu l'as su t'es visionnaire
Pardon Alain
Sans toi
On a ouvert le dictionnaire
T'as reconnu
Nos voix
On jongle avec les mots
Tout le monde encore
Une fois
C'est Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo
Tout le monde encore
Une fois
C'est Squeezie, Oli, Bigflo
Clap
*Clap*
*Cris*
*Applaudissement*